ils viennent d'avoir les résultats du
concours de descendre et s'ils sont là
c'est que ces résultats sont décevants
soit ils ont échoué soit leur classement
ne leur permet plus d'espérer la filière
de leur choix par exemple médecine alors
il faut rebondir et sont ici pour
essayer de trouver une autre vocation
une autre voie quelque chose qui
pourrait les faire rebondir et les faire
les faire avancer dans la vie sans
forcément se dire qu'à la fin d'un pass
est définie indiqué les issue pour
sortir de l'impasse voilà la mission que
se donne les tuteurs de la fac de
médecine
voici quelques années l'université
proposer un semestre rebonds pour aider
les étudiants à se réorienter supprimés
faute de budget alors le tutorat supplay
l'institution on touche à tout on fait
de la chimie de lave et de la botanique
qui ont fait de la la qu'est ce qu'on
fait de la pharmaco ont fait de la
galénique ont fait pour domaine qui au
final en fait on se rend compte se
regroupe on fait de la biochimie ont
fait voilà moi je suis passé j'ai fait
deux princesses c'était compliqué pour
moi c'est pas forcément utiliser tous
les services qui étaient déjà là et je
m'en suis voulu parce que
ça aurait pu m'aider dans tous mes choix
virgile effectue lui aussi sa deuxième
passe s est il préférant anticiper une
éventuelle déconvenue en venant
s'informer je suis un peu la limite pour
métier c'est-à-dire le numerus et à 230
je suis à peu près dans les deux sens
mais au cas où je voulais regarder s'il
y'avait échec par exemple regarder un
petit peu les autres filières que nous
propose l'université certains veulent se
réorienter dans quelque chose d'assez
médicale parce que c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont qui sont entrés en bassesse et
d'autres veulent vraiment mettre une
croix sur la paces et changer totalement
de vocation pour trouver quelque chose
d'autre à faire et de fait si les
professionnels des secteurs paramédicaux
sont les plus sollicités des étudiants
s'intéressent aussi par exemple à
l'ouverture prochaine à dijon d'une
école de design élaboré un plan b voir
qu'on n'est pas tout seul à se chercher
cette initiative des tuteurs est en tout
cas la bienvenue pour tous ces jeunes